Data is at the center of nearly every product you own,
your phone, your TV, even your car.
Products have become increasingly customized to your needs with the help of data,
allowing companies like Netflix, Uber,
and Amazon to build great data-driven products.
Since every product is data-driven,
the melding of data science and product management is the future or product development.
Data product managers understand that building
products that incorporate data requires a data strategy,
a plan for how data will be collected, transform,
and analyze, [inaudible] position your product to win in the market.
In Udacity's Data Product Manager Nanodegree program,
you'll learn how to build data-driven products backed by
scalable data strategies to deliver
the right experiences to the right users at the right time.
In this Nanodegree program,
you'll evaluate market data and create
visualizations to determine the key matrices and features for a new product.
You will integrate this data backed evidence into a product proposal
that is supported by a scalable data pipeline and warehousing strategy.
Once you finish, you'll be able to create a data product concept,
strategize a data pipeline and storage infrastructure to support scaling of the product,
and enhance the product design based on user data,
leverage data to build products that position customers and businesses to thrive.
Enroll in Udacity's Data Product Manager Nanodegree program today.